enabling people with visual impairments
to navigate virtual reality with a
haptic and auditory cane simulation
virtual reality experiences today rely
primarily on the visual channel to
create an immersive experience which
makes them inaccessible for people with
visual impairments we created a novel VR
experience by using haptic and audio
feedback to enable people with visual
impairments to experience the virtual
world our novel haptic controller
simulates the interaction of a white
cane to help people who are blind
understand and navigate a virtual space
using their existing orientation and
mobility skills this haptic controller
is paired with an HTC vive headset used
for tracking the users head position and
for delivering 3d spatial audio through
headphones no visual feedback is
rendered in front of the users eyes our
controller consists of five parts an
active braking mechanism anchored on the
users waist a cane controller that a
user holds in their hand a slider that
connects the brake and the controller a
voice coil mounted on the tip of the
cane controller to generate vibrotactile
sensations and an HTC vive tracker on
the controller to track the controller's
movement while our keen controller is
much shorter than a typical white cane
to avoid hitting real obstacles in the
room it's a virtual counterpart can be
as long as needed typically the length
of these is real cane when the virtual
cane hits on a virtual object for
example a trash can the brake stops the
controller from moving generating the
illusion that a real object stopped the
canes movement meanwhile the voice coil
generates a vibration that simulates the
high frequency vibration when a cane
hits a real object the system also
provides corresponding 3d spatial sound
to simulate the sound of a real cane
hitting on a specific object with the
tactile and audio feedback a blind user
can walk along a virtual wall by
continuously sweeping and tapping the
wall which is a standard cane skill
called Shore lining another standard
cane technique is called constantcontact
which is when a user sweeps the Kin
controller on the ground the voice coil
generates corresponding vibrations to
simulate the texture
the ground our controller modulates both
amplitude and speed of the audio and
vibrotactile feedback based on the
user's movements for example our
controller can render tactile domes on a
crosswalk ramp here we also use the
brake to provide a short resistance when
the tip of the virtual cane sweeps
across each bump on the tactile dome to
provide the illusion that the cane hits
the bump users can also tap on different
virtual surfaces with the cane
controller both the voice coil
vibrations and the 3d spatial audio are
used here to generate the haptics and
sound mimicking the real cane sensations
on a specific material with this
technique a blind user can conduct
two-point touch a standard cane skill he
used to navigate the environment notice
that we allow for significant tolerance
with the floor penetration since though
our canes break can stop horizontal
movement it cannot stop vertical motion
since we don't physically limit the
users motion in space we play a beeping
sound to indicate when the user has
penetrated the boundary of available
space for example our system will be if
the cane penetrates too deep into the
wall or the floor to understand the
ability of our system to render a
virtual space to the visually impaired
user we conducted a usability study with
people who are visually impaired the
participants were familiarized with our
controller and then asked to explore an
indoor and an outdoor scene our indoor
scene consisted of a room with four
walls a carpet a door a table and a
trash can the study showed that eight
out of nine participants could
understand the layout of the virtual
room and correctly locate the position
of all virtual objects by using the king
controller after only a few minutes of
practice using the system the outdoor
scene simulated a street crossing with a
sidewalk a curb with tactile domes a
traffic light and a busy street with
cars going by participants were able to
identify different parts of the scene
understand the flow of traffic in the
street and were able to cross the street
based on the audio signal from the
traffic light
I found the pole in the traffic light
button our study provides evidence that
our novel virtual reality cane
controller enables people who are blind
to explore and understand an unfamiliar
virtual space this technology has the
potential to enable novel accessible
applications for virtual reality such as
orientation and mobility training